so let's say i totally agree with you
that the left right thing is being
pushed on to the people as a way to
divide us and distract us right your
fellow citizen is not your enemy right
they just want you to think your fellow
citizen is your enemy yes polarization
now is rising and rising on both sides
where 42 percent of both them democrats
and republicans think the other side is
uh evil morally bankrupt uh you know
threat to the country that sort of thing
um and so one reason i started the
forward party is because i think that
this polarization is going to lead us to
violence
uh unrest uh over time
um and that if you could frame it as
uh
the people versus the establishment or
something along those lines you could
bring people together
the forward party
uh is trying to send the message you
just articulated which is that other
americans are not your enemy
unfortunately right now you have
billions of dollars in media and
other incentives trying to to pit us
against each other
so i have an approach that i'm enjoying
which is say look you have these two
camps that are
so somewhat artificial and like you know
the average person who's not super
engaged actually is you know like and i
i'm proud to say that i reached some
people who weren't politically activated
um previously
um that if you find someone who's
non-ideological then a lot of common
sense
is very very widespread like the common
sense actually diminishes though the
more politically activated you get uh in
in
many of the conversations i've had um
but if you want to try and change this
dynamic you need to have a third party
um and then you would want a different
dynamic in the media because right now
you have the democratic alliance media
and the republican media so you would
need independent voices to come up that
represent something distinct from either
so that's the project i'm embarking on
the alternate version of this for
someone uh who has some of the same
goals
that you articulated would be to try and
transform the democratic party and the
chief way people see that quote-unquote
transform the democratic party would be
to run for a president
let's say in a democratic nomination
process the way you and i both did just
in this last cycle yes we do now there
are a couple of problems with that
one being that the democratic party is
going to be very unfriendly to
candidates who
are trying to transform much of anything
and i'm going to say that's
approximately 100 times more true in
this upcoming cycle i agree because we
were inconvenient last time and they're
not even they don't even want us on the
first debate stage this time i'm not
even sure there will be a debate stage
that's an interesting way to look at it
as well right so so there was an article
that came out that you were quoted in
that asked whether someone was going to
primary joe biden
and you said categorically as someone
will because the people
want that
and
i believe that if someone did primary
joe biden there's a certain level of
support that they would get pretty
quickly because there are any number of
people that want bigger set of changes
than they're getting or joe was never
the candidate or you know what have you
i also think that the deck is going to
be stacked against anyone who decides to
challenge joe and that even the people
who are considered progressives who are
let's say in congress right now that
they are not going to
undertake this uh because the pressure
will be too great
and so
as someone who is on record saying hey i
totally think someone's going to
challenge joe first
who do you think might undertake this
challenge
uh and then second
um what do you think about the fact that
i'm sure the deck is going to be stacked
against that person or a set of people
it could be more than one one person
well first of all we don't know for sure
whether the president will run again
that's number one
a lot of the people that you say will
not step forward if he does run again
might make a different decision if he's
not running again oh if he's not running
everyone comes out i think right now
they're making clear that their two main
choices they meaning the elite
establishment within the democratic
party they are clearly in love with pete
and amy
right
my analysis of how the elite democrats
would act towards a real progressive
running is exactly as yours but i've
heard a lot of people talk about how
bernie didn't have to acquiesce
and bernie could have made it clear that
if you treat me that way you know one of
the moments in the republican stage
which was very interesting if you
remember
they said to trump early in the process
on the stage do you promise
that if you
do not win the nomination that you will
support the republican candidate do you
remember his answer his answer was it
depends on how you guys treat me
you look back at that and think that's
exactly what the answer should be so
follow someone doing that that would be
my answer it depends on how you guys
treat me
political parties are not even mentioned
in the constitution george washington
warned us against them in his farewell
address john adams said that they
represented the greatest threat to
democracy this idea that they get to be
the gatekeepers they are when in court
the democratic party
argued that they don't owe it to people
to let the person who got the most votes
win we have to call the duopolistic
system on what it is and let's remember
the duopoly is actually a monopoly you
know we talk like how divided we are
they are not all that divided because
the bottom line is the
military-industrial complex will get
what they want on that we are not
divided
oil companies more than not
more than not will continue to do what
they want to do on that we are not
divided big pharmaceutical companies
will continue to obstruct any chance of
universal health care on that we are not
divided they divide us so that we don't
recognize how undivided they are in some
very essential ways if you accept this
is the set of issues and then you say
option one
run as uh progressive in the democratic
primary transform the party and don't
pretend that the democratic party is any
different than it is that you make part
of your campaign to point out that the
democratic party as bernie sanders has
been saying has strayed from its
traditional role of of true champion of
the working people of the united states
if it continues to be this basically
corporatist
machinery it will not
have a chance to beat donald trump have
you seen some of the
commentary
uh that bernie should have started a
third party i guess people are
successful yes that's what people are
saying people are saying he shouldn't
have stopped
that when they when they suppressed him
both times he said well i'm keeping on
walking because i'm running for
president and i'm not going to be
stopped i'm supported by the american
people this isn't about whether or not
the democratic party is giving me
permission and he's not even a democrat
technically why should he allow
something stopping him from doing it if
you think about people that could have
started a successful third party over
this recent number of years bernie's at
the top of the list oh absolutely and
many people's frustration with him is
that he didn't just keep walking um
that's not criticism it's just as as i
said frustration the question i think
people have for you is number one
whether you'll be able to garner enough
money to really
um make the difference that you'd like
to make
number two whether or not there will be
enough diversity you know what third
parties have done and that's part of the
problem even calling it a third party um
what they've done traditionally is that
they've just kind of anointed a
candidate
my hope for the forward party would be
that you'd have a lot of really good
people running um including for
president so that you know a friend of
mine was saying the other day you know
if the forward party gets a lot of
really good people from diverse
political places running
their debate will be the more
interesting one that people will want to
watch in 2024 because that
if the president runs again i think it's
if there was even a debate at that point
but people
the democratic party has become so yadda
yadda i think of the republican party as
representing a nosedive for our
democracy and i think of the democratic
party as representing a managed decline
for our democracy and neither one of
them they represent such a solid status
quo it is not going to interrupt itself
this is going to take an intervention by
the american people i like the idea of
rejuvenation and i also love the idea of
having an independent nomination process
for the forward party uh where anyone
can participate and you can imagine
that primary being fascinating because
you have hundreds of people running if
not more well there'd be so many people
too
um that would realize that they'd get a
fair shake uh outside of the democratic
party or the republican party
now so the republican party just a quick
you know like
synopsis of how that's going to go down
so
you'll have trump running
um he'll be running against uh generally
some second-tier types who feel they
have no choice but to run against trump
and hope something breaks their way um
so it's going to be mike pence maybe
mike pompeo chris christie nikki haley
um i think nikki haley nikki haley's
already publicly said she does run
against trump um so she's uh taking
herself out if trump is there ron
desantis has privately said he will not
run against trump if trump is there um
so that's one reason i'm saying that
either one of those could be his vp
candidate that's part of it
and so they're also on the younger side
they're like yeah i'll sit out one cycle
and then just come back around whereas
if they go against trump then it could
be a career destroyer destroyer because
a lot of the base republican party could
turn on them in a lasting way
so that's one reason why trump's
opposition will likely be the
relatively uh less strong candidates the
strongest candidate that seems poised to
run against him in my opinion is larry
hogan of maryland who's turned out oh
because he would be more the
yeah
young yeah let's say you were um an
independent human who wanted to run for
president if you try to insert yourself
in the republican primary you're not
going to get a real shot given that
trump will be taking up all the oxygen
there'll be some other figures
[Music]
you